we'll just jump this one really quick
well uh sure so this is a story that's
been popping up quite a bit because
we're all locked in our homes yeah we
were joking about it multiple times
right there's gonna be a bunch of babies
we talked about in the show Kerr
O'Neill's and there's actually two
things a baby boom and a huge spike in
divorce rates yeah because people are
trapped with each other now but uh well
some people have argued it'll be no no
we won't see baby boom will see divorce
and it's like I don't think you
understand you can see both yeah you
know the people gonna have kids and
that's kind of a bad thing but the
Washington Post said we might see a
corona virus maybe blip not a boom I
don't agree there's a lot of reasons for
the baby boom well boom was over a
course of years not one like I mean I
hope they also over years they also
didn't quarantine their entire
population which was much smaller well
that's why it's gonna be a crazy blip
instead of a boom
you know maybe in nine months like right
around now hospitals will be overrun yes
pregnant women yep for real and schools
I hope few years later yeah that's the
blip it makes sense oh I see what
they're saying no it's a boom is like a
slow roll in expansion it was like that
whole era of like where we finally beat
the recession we're building like
America yeah you know so so but here's
why I think it it's guaranteed to happen
some people say well we don't actually
know people are gonna hook up and have
babies right yeah sure condom shortage
looms after coronavirus lockdown shuts
world's top producer boom baby's coming
everyone's grabbing the toilet paper
toilet paper and then they weren't
showing this but they would ride around
the aisle and grab all the condoms - are
they really doing that no no but this is
Kuala Lumpur a global shortage of
condoms is looming so all right I'm
kidding right now we have condoms so
people are gonna get them so we'll see
what happens if in nine months is a
major boom we go tomorrow it's like for
some reason people all across America
were running to the store and buying out
condoms
at one moment 12,000 people went out
right around my Stern and Andrade all
the condoms yes
so the Washington Post says thanks to
the coronavirus Americans have been
locked out of their offices and told to
work from home there's no eating out
well depends on your definition oh I'm
so funny no recreational shopping and no
hanging with friends almost all events
are canceled and no one can travel
there's not even live sports on TV
seriously man boring of the many
questions his extreme situation raises
one will have to wait several months for
an answer should we expect expect a
coronavirus baby boom a surprising
amount of research has been done on the
subject of post disaster fertility the
headline hypothesis is fairly
straightforward with other activity
curtailed couples have more opportunity
and perhaps more desire for intimacy
nine months later the babies show up
this theory was behind other words
that's it yes yes the stork comes this
theory was behind a series of articles
published at by the New York Times in
the aftermath of the great New York City
blackout of November 1965 when several
local hospitals registered an increase
in births starting in August in 1966 The
Times attributed the spike to how the
infant's parents kept busy when the
lights went out hold on so I had a
question yeah how long was the blackout
ya know how stuck inside a couple years
no they said blip it's not a boom years
I am worried I think we're gonna be
locked on for a long time man I don't
think anyone under Maryland's lockdown
is indefinite they given they've given
no exploration right yeah that's
frightening so the closest comparison
these people have is like weather events
and the blackout in 1966 look it up very
very short the wiki they say sociologist
J Richard a dream wanted to test the
assumption for himself in a 1970
published his findings as it turned out
upon reviewing the citywide data
Adri found no statistically significant
increase or decrease in the number of
conceptions during the blackout yet ever
since each new disaster seems to have
brought reports of a surge in births if
a lack of alternative entertainment
doesn't spur a cove at night
baby boom Mike the widespread calls to
come together for the sake of our civil
Asian civilization inspire people to
start working on the next generation
high really doubt it this banding
together theory was one of the main
explanations in a 2005 study showing an
increase in births in the countries
surrounding in the counties surrounding
Oklahoma City after the 1995 bombing of
the Alfred P murrah Federal Building
when a population unites around a common
goal people feel more ownership of the
future we might therefore expect more
baby-making to result from the
nationwide campaign against the
coronavirus you know I think it's
actually we have no purpose and because
we have no purpose there's no need to
reproduce and I don't think it's
necessarily about people being occupied
with other things I think it's like so I
was reading that people die most after
retirement like that's true right that's
true typically when people retire they
die within a year well you know I think
that it you know I think I could be
wrong but here's my personal hypothesis
I never heard that yeah it's huge but
most less like fifty five to sixty right
but especially guys I guess yeah they
retire they don't purpose soon after
retirement think about the advantage in
evolution if someone is no longer
producing for the collective for the try
before the family there are drag on
resources they're no longer working that
are producing them dying would be a net
benefit to the rest of to the survival
survivability of the family because now
they need less resources so if you have
ten people and you know one Buffalo can
feed ten people and one person does no
work everyone is doing extra work to
support the person who doesn't there are
some people they found this in the Blue
Zones the areas where people live to be
over 100 one factor is that they all
work well into their you know 90s or
hundred there was one interview I saw
enough was an interview but there's a
guy in Japan and it was a really old guy
in his 90s chopping lumber chopping wood
and they were like you're 90 why do you
still do this and he said if I don't who
will
yeah so one of the big factors in
survival was you know it was that moving
so I wonder if the reason people don't
have babies
is for the same reason we know
internally we're not doing anything to
better our society it would be a drain
on society - you know reproduce in a
world where there's no purpose anymore
so now that we have an actual common
threaten of
and our survivability is under threat
people all of a sudden now start
reigniting a desire to have kids and
they might it might be subconscious it
might just be like all of a sudden like
I'm gonna have kids and it could be
because now we are actually being
threatened or like what we were talking
about the other a couple maybe a month
ago now is like how this whole thing
bringing factories back to America feels
like bringing Americans back together so
it's like back to the 1950s
well you know it doesn't have to be back
in the 1950s you know but still bringing
production back here is simply a thing
that could can be bringing people
together it's like a lot of people on
either side are like we should make our
own medicine like China shouldn't have
control over our medicine that's like
that's pretty broad you know it's like
but a lot of people believe that so it's
like we should start working towards
that and then the the we in that
sentence is the key you know it's like
so maybe it's already kind of begun and
now we're quarantined so right but do
you think people like people are
consciously saying like I think we
should have children for the sake of our
country no it's it's more of like a like
a comfort thing I guess you know they're
I mean obviously in this situation it's
not really comfortable but the thought
of having kids isn't as scary you know
because yeah there's there is something
there for them
we're building something we can rely on
each other right well maybe exactly when
you start to think that there might not
be a future you start thinking about the
future any like well if I want to have
kids yeah you know what other people
should think of me well maybe it's also
this maybe for a lot of women who are
working they never have the opportunity
so now that people are at home they're
thinking we're know how long it's gonna
take how one's gonna last there's a
window now where you can't work it's
like one of the one of the concerns I
read about cuz I'm not a woman so I
wouldn't know is that if women choose to
have a family they take time off work
and it holds them back if now everyone
has take time off work mm-hmm
you're on the same no detriment yeah so
yeah maybe we gotta have a bunch kids so
we can raise the farm in the old-school
way that's right get to work kiss VRC
theory time there
Wow Wow in the fields Reata raise the
corn up that's the conspiracy the
governments of the world are seeing the
declining birthrate of all of the
different countries and we're like we
got to figure how to lock everyone
homes yeah and make them terrified of
their own mortality and you know what
it's interesting cuz I'm kidding
seriously yeah but there's a lot of
people are going out and buying food
buying a lot of things buying stuff yeah
spending money and wow it's true but the
economy no I know it's almost like a
hard reset though yeah exact all of a
sudden now our farmers and our grocery
store workers our most important jobs
truckers mmm it used to be like
celebrities yeah you know you know when
you take like a I'm gonna pull well
doctors Nintendo 64 you take the disc
out it was a hard trade oh yeah blow it
reset so that wins that you use is covet
nineteen boom put it back in if we if we
have a hard enough we have a hard resin
to our economy and all of a sudden now
we're like truckers doctors nurses
police
EMTs like core jobs that actually make
society function are now getting you
know people are clapping and cheering
you see these videos yeah like a nurse
walk outside and ever in the
neighborhood screaming and clapping and
she's like you know thank you or
whatever and you don't even know if at
our hospital they're overwhelmed some
places they are some places they aren't
so it's kind of like a back-to-basics
thing yeah where people are gonna come
out of this being like what do we need
to build because celebrity ain't it you
know we don't need to cheer I mean we'll
still have them for sure right but right
now the celebrities are going insane in
their in their bedroom and everyone's
watching and may go out of it there you
like you're in a mansion you have how
are you not you know you're literally
crying in your mansion bro we're not
we're not interested to hear about your
attic know this is up to actually
another interesting point is all of a
sudden now they're not sympathizing with
the wealthy people crying in their
apartments because they see how bad it
is for the doctors and nurses actually
catching this getting sick or putting
themselves at risk and still out there
working back in the like before all this
broke out a celebrity would cry and
people would be like leave them alone
you don't understand how hard it is to
be a famous celebrity now it's like
either do you but but now it's
mainstream to mock you celebrities it's
true now everyone's jumping in on making
fun of them mm-hmm not even the
celebrities right they're realizing it's
not cool to be the weirdo yeah like you
have to make fun of the weirdo wait this
isn't working anymore
oh no yeah my whole my whole premise is
built on this
well I guess we'll uh we'll have to wait
and see what's uh what is it it's it's
March so November gosh March March 97th
March is April's just around the next
year yep well come November October
November December we'll start to see
stuff we'll see we'll see what happens
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you